es un hombre que conocemos desde hace
mucho tiempo
y que solo ahora sale a la luz destinado
a reinar desde la infancia
Carlos espero 70 años para subir al
Trono
a la sombra de su madre Isabel segunda
Carlos ha tenido tiempo de aprender y
observar los cambios en este mundo
fue el primero del Clan Windsor el
licenciarse
se sumergió en los libros tecnologías
etnografía
ha pensado mucho es un hombre muy culto
sí es una mente ilustrada
utiliza estos conocimientos para
promover la ecología
los ojos y las esperanzas del mundo
entero están puestos en ustedes para que
actúen sin demora y sin temblar porque
el tiempo se acaba
es alguien que desarrolló muy pronto un
verdadero sentido de la ecología hace 40
años Fue el primero la gente pensaba que
estaba loco hablaba con los árboles
hablaba con las plantas quería permear
la cultura antes que nadie
para poner en práctica sus ideas
construyó ciudades modelos en sus
tierras de dorset mientras sus granjas
vendían productos ecológicos en el
mercado local
de sus granjas obtenían ingresos para
financiar sus fundaciones Empezando por
la fundación Princess Trust para jóvenes
necesitados
siempre vale la pena aunque solo sea una
persona que despliega su talento y su
potencial para lograr lo que realmente
desea Esto es lo que nos motiva a todos
Así que la pregunta es cómo podemos
marcar la diferencia en la vida de las
personas
lo que ha hecho es ofrecer a personas
que proceden de entornos diferentes
países pobres o familias pobres la
oportunidad de hacer lo que quieran en
la vida dándoles becas y oportunidades
que normalmente no habrían tenido Eso
está muy bien
a pesar de estos activos Carlos no
siempre fue popular
ensombrecido por su joven y bella esposa
Diana se divorció de ella en 1996 un año
antes de su muerte en un accidente en
París
En aquel momento la corona temblaba
25 años después
Carlos accedió al Trono con su segunda
esposa al lado Camila
es la venganza de Camila a la que
llamaban la bruja la rottweiler la otra
mujer la villana
no solo se ha convertido en reina
consorte sino que para la coronación
pasa a ser Su Majestad la reina Camila
la gente
ya son una pareja mayor llevan casados
desde 2005 ella se ha ganado su puesto
a pesar de su edad la pareja real no
debería estar sin trabajo
el reinado comienza en un momento de
crisis para el país
[Música]
y miembros de la cámara de los comunes
más que nunca el rey debe desempeñar su
papel como el puente que mantiene unida
a la nación
[Música]
estamos en un país multiétnico como
Francia donde debemos hacer que todas
las personas de otros orígenes se
sientan bienvenidas
cree que puede encarnar este periodo
postura personal
manteniendo este vínculo con América y
con los países del commonwells
el commonwell está conformado por más de
50 países la mayoría de los cuales
pertenecieron al imperio británico y
Carlos es su jefe
oficialmente reina sobre 15 de ellos
pero varios están pensando en
emanciparse de la corona lo que
debilitaría al nuevo rey Pues el mayor
logro de los windsors es que siguen
existiendo en El Siglo 21
el principal reto para el rey es
perpetuar la familia real porque en los
últimos sondeos más del 17% de los
británicos están a favor de una
República en comparación con hace 10
años aún más preocupante para la
monarquía muy pocos jóvenes entre 18 y
25 años están ahora a favor de la
monarquía
la familia real se ha visto sacudida
recientemente por un escándalo sexual en
el que se ha visto implicado el príncipe
Andrew y por las salidas de alto nivel
del príncipe Harry y su esposa Megan Así
que los windsors necesitan cerrar filas
si esperan prolongar la historia de la
corona británica
[Música]